to Ramsey intent and first of all let's
start off with saying a big thank you to
every other NHS at what extraordinary
yet again and your work has been
phenomenal and more importantly true
true true
superstars everyone and having family
work of NHS I know how hard you are
working so thank you and God bless
right Rams in 10 I'm gonna make the most
amazing color my favorite curry is the
butter chicken but this is occurring
with a twist because it's sort of it's
great for the kids and it's got
butternut squash if you don't get
Ponder's question there trust me we can
use courgettes or zucchini as we say in
the u.s. it's simple it's delicious and
then why not let us know what you think
I don't know direction today is the
Matilda the sensation and peanut peanut
you stink tell us right okay curry
ingredients right but are we ready stop
the clock please
thank you ten minutes yes right first
off hands off I'm using a nonstick pan
again told you I bought this about four
weeks ago from Tesco's I think it's
about eight ninety ninety five
incredible
that's what little surprise at the end
I'll do something sort of pretty
majestic goes perfectly well with curry
you don't need me to show you how to
cook vice okay so that you know what's
happened over the last two months you
guys have turned into a national through
this this is how we do a quick curry
midweek especially the kids are here
everywhere pan on let's pan down please
tell you but can you don't please madam
red onion but this question spilled a
small knob of ginger a beautiful fresh
chili chicken oh he's impressive okay
there's two breasts this chicken dish is
enough for six but thighs are brilliant
if you want to use the drums just keep
the drums whole but I'm taking the bone
out off the top of the breast after that
we've got some fresh frozen peas coconut
milk chopped Kenta martyrs little bit
chicken stock curry powder and little
touch of olive oil
first off forget the chopping for a
moment okay an illegal all chopped but
box grater take the top off the purple
that squash I just grate it okay now as
you start grating open up your hand I
need extra two minutes by the way
because that was introduction so again
yes please your top tonight chills start
going please okay thank you yeah office
is hungry okay from there literally
great now I love II would never think
about putting a pumpkin inside the Korea
but also for my beloved by churns out
there a pumpkin Corolla sown from the
same way with vegetable stock is just as
delicious
now look from there from there and then
just there this is where you go slowly
now okay right from there look great
just test it make with you
okay now button let's squat a little
water I can't get the pan nice pot and
first off let me start cooking now a
little drizzle yes
drizzle truly you are wrong one today
use the pan and spread the pedlar squash
throughout so make when you start
grating these vegetables the sort of the
yield okay it's very very very sort of
you know cost-effective from there right
that guess up a touch of salt
Carlos please from there lightly
seasoned get your curry powder okay now
you can use a beautiful canvas Allah
this is just a beautiful color palette
fragrant and just likely to sprinkle
that over a butternut squash two and a
half teaspoon no camera salah beautiful
fragrant delicious you're not working
there now okay use the pan on the
outside and start cooking all that these
will button a squash
now the onion again hold it almost like
a cricket ball in and just let you start
grating again and this sort of makes it
a lot easier
I tell you why as it starts to cook it's
sort of pretty much disintegrates and
more importantly I use the red onion
because of the sort of sweetness the
less bitter than a white onion and
honestly it's a sort of very mild flavor
tune is gone
I know it's go in a hurry for tipping
you do have to push me okay that's what
my job here I've never seen an
ungrateful alright okay from there lift
that up tap
okay and they get that onion in there
now
beautiful on that family set up a little
bit of color on that beautiful let's
watch now you can see why we only need a
touch of oil in there and that's firm
that squash great it gives a really nice
sort of rich texture to the curry it's
pretty incredible okay again just a
touch of sticky bit on top of the onions
and now get the chili okay all I go to
the season again roll nice and flat this
much spicy yes but honestly as the curry
sort of cooks you need that little bit
of heat in there okay
fresh chili now the ginger okay get that
literally almost sweating off again to
get the back of the spoon and spread it
across the pan this way it cooks so much
quicker okay and that we really chopped
the chili look what's inside the pan get
a little microplane get the knob of
ginger and grate that
okay again hold it nice and firm no rush
what what happens now is that this sort
of ginger disintegrates beautifully and
it gets really nice and pureed pan down
please move that pin down see look at
that with all that beautiful juice okay
and again gins debate michaelis okay
incredibly fibrous it's very very hard
to sort of you know to find ice and then
when you start dicing it on top of the
board the board's wet and all the flavor
ginger has gone into the board so I want
the flavor of the ginger in the curry so
he grate it oh that's right from there
tap-tap-tap keep your knife in there and
just nifty great all that down
oh no come back down please now look at
that the smell of that is incredible
like I said I'm using curry powder the
nice thing about this dish make your own
spice mix make your own garam masala
beautiful sweating off like that it's
almost like a paste in there okay and
the good news is we've taken out the
water
okay now creates a little sort of hole
in the center from their disability
spoon all falling again and then get
your chicken okay now chicken in okay
this is a breast of chicken something
that cooks go quickly depending on the
time bright cover smaller or bigger you
want to do it in 20 minutes a bit chunky
I like them in a little slice taste on
that aroma
yeah mess the chicken is silly now again
no this is one of the most easiest
delicious curries you'll ever do
importantly as it sits in the fridge
what you don't use honestly the next day
is incredible now okay
peas in okay peez go in that's gonna
give a little bit of sort of texture and
freshness with this curry now look at
spinach okay baby spits they go at the
very very end let me do this
vegetarians love then obviously no
chicken no stock preparation stock lots
of pumpkin butternut squash the zucchini
and not the spinach is so good now look
at that look pin down please pan down
Tilly the chicken is still in there okay
now for some richness chopped tomatoes
go in turn up the gas
after that give them a little stir you
can see it started to come together
from there the coconut milk and that
gives it a sort of sweetness also it
gives a little added richness it's a
really nice you're supposed to Pender
hands of the Hat now pull that in bring
that up to the boil and this is where
you start to think wow do I need a touch
more stock again just a couple of
tablespoons of stock you don't go stop
all asleep water is fine bring that up
to the boil and simmer gently now let
that simmer it taste it don't crack the
seasoning
now what's the perfect economy okay
where the poet no rocky breads okay this
is so simple that we said it rice
clearly yes of course but brent once a
word you break this is so super okay
I've got a hundred twenty grams of flour
okay a little pinch of salt okay a soon
blood of olive oil and about 120 grams
of water this is such a lovely
accompaniment start rolling the water
round fold that in okay and all going to
do now is get to sort of a nice soft
dough texture panned out the curry
please look at those flavors thank you
listen it's a curry in a hurry was
delicious one go you just pan down to
the boat please
I know no but this hopper is now little
bring that back okay
and all we gonna do is shake that into a
little dough if you let that rest for
about 15 minutes okay what happens now
it starts to relax I'm from there it
sort of forms this beautiful light bread
dough the rock salt gives it the most
incredible flavor okay but no I
beautiful board let that sit and relax
obviously I made one earlier I've cut it
into four okay look from there all these
beautiful
billboards pat-down please across to the
quarry yes yeah busy busy
now quick the seizing first that cooks
well look at texture well touch up some
delicious I'm not just saying you can't
taste it I read you
I promise you from there okay when
you're cooking always ping down the side
of the pan
I know another way too much time that
chickens will you cook I need to like
flour your hands like hot pan on ok
nothing in there ok ok and then love
with the bread just literally roll these
out okay now I quite like that I'm sort
of thin okay and the more you let this
relax okay
it better have become turn it over pull
it along okay get nice and thin they
gets really nice and toasty on the
outside
fold it over like that and then go on to
the next one okay touch of flour
I know time to learn oh look
two more minutes please look how down
please and see what you let this dough
relax it's so easy to roll and it makes
the most amazing bread the curry but
I've got a little trip to it okay once
it's nicely thing like that you can roll
it back onto the roller okay
lightly salt the pan okay a splash of
all in there okay and watch take that
it's nice and thin piece the pan she
goes okay like the gas that's in full
look watch that roast now fine back up
to here please the spinach just finished
being rinsed okay lay that spinach over
okay and then get a spoon
what what happens the Seville is almost
sort of disintegrates but gives it a
really nice brightness to the curry and
two tablespoons of cocoa powder a fresh
chili and literally in nine minutes you
can see that chicken is what he cut if I
was using the most amazing fine and let
it cook a little bit longer the spinach
takes seconds to cook but look at that
inside or you can put chickpeas in there
I've got fresh peas and spinach pan down
the bread please over to the end and
push away and flip push away and flip
and then bang back down now that fresh
bread there is beautifully crisp I mean
really crisp the chicken got texture
below honestly it's so beautiful so
beautiful now just the smoke let that
simmer when I get hold of that that this
bread literally takes 90 seconds each
side and then beautiful spoons okay I
sort of build up the excitement with
that it's nice and thick and by
literally okay grating that button there
squash put the texture and then from
there fit your bread straight out of the
pan literally there you have the most
amazing curry you know but it is 11
minutes and 58 seconds a delicious curry
now please enjoy I never get hot out
there today but making this for the
weekend obviously isn't
[Music]